my name is jessica miller i work at
microsoft research in redmond i work as
a research software development engineer
i work on a team of designers and
project managers and developers and
testers that help support researchers
when they want to take their research
ideas and either publish them in the
academic world or put them into
Microsoft products many stars aligned to
allow me to pick this profession but the
one that is probably most important is
that computer science is very practical
and what I did in the classroom I could
see it being what i did in the real
world I work at Microsoft because I had
an internship here seven or eight years
ago and I really enjoyed the team and
stayed in contact with the manager and
got a position with him what I actually
do on a daily basis kind of depends on
the day I get a new project completely
different project once every six months
or so so I'm constantly learning so a
lot of my job is just learning about the
latest project and the technologies
we're using a lot of it is coordinating
between designers and researchers and
myself and other engineers and then a
lot of it is coding as well I
collaborate with other people in my job
mainly with the researchers because
we're taking their ideas and trying to
polish them up for product but I also
work with designers to make their
technology perhaps prettier more fun to
use and then I also collaborate with my
fellow colleagues to try to solve
problems and learn about the different
technologies we're using if you think
about creative and being the sense of
creating things that's the entire
definition of being an engineer you're
building things so I'm building software
every day and then from the more
artistic perspective or connotation of
creative there's a lot of creativity and
designing and building interesting user
interfaces for people one of my favorite
projects is clip 'let's
that I'm working on right now what a
clip lid is is a mix of two different
kinds of media its a mix of a photo and
also a video so you can take a video
choose a still frame and then choose
moving parts in the video so you get
like a Harry Potter like piece of media
that you can share with your friends and
family clip 'let's is pretty fun because
it's a new type of digital media and
people can tell different sorts of
stories than they can with just a photo
or just a video they're actually kind of
captivating like a lot of times I'm
supposed to be working and I end up just
watching a clip light over and over
again because it's really cute or tells
like a really nice story that couldn't
have been told with just a photo or just
a video one thing I really appreciate is
clear thinking clear logical thinking
it's kind of a beautiful thing when a
particular argument for example is
constructed in a really nice way
similarly with code if code is
constructed in a really nice structured
logical way that someone can just pick
up that code and develop off it and
build off it it's just it's a joy to see
that sort of thinking that is very
helpful in programming when you're
coding trying to figure out an algorithm
or how to do something you know you
really know it when you can code it I
was a PhD student for a little while at
the University of Washington and while I
was there I worked with a professor in
the I school who was interested in
understanding how the software
development process happens in terms of
making sure people's values get
incorporated into the technology a
famous example of a value that is not
frequently incorporated or put at risk
is privacy so tons of technologies are
being developed and we're putting our
information out there and we actually
don't have a whole lot of control over
how this information gets used and so
this professor was very interested and
how we software designers and developers
can be a little bit better about
building these technologies when I got
my internship at Microsoft Research I
was really lucky because my manager was
very open-minded
and he let me build this piece of
software and alongside that do this
design process of trying to make sure
people's values are incorporated into
this software so it was pretty great
because I got to act right and actual
product that got used within Microsoft
and I actually got to write a thesis out
of it as well as do something really
interesting and different I don't really
know anyone else other than me that's
gotten to be able to do something like
that when I think about mentors that
I've had my best mentors have been
informal ones so one of my best friends
I went to grad school with him and he is
a computer geek from day one so as we
were working on projects together he was
a fabulous educator honestly so even
though we were peers he really mentored
me and a lot of the principles that I
use and techniques that I use still come
from honestly my best friend I suppose
the piece of advice I'd like to give
someone in computer science right now is
do an internship do you want as soon as
possible because that's how you'll get
to know what you'll be doing on a
day-to-day basis and then you just meet
all kinds of people you start to
understand what you like what you don't
like you know trial by error do an
internship on the prompt ECMO I think
that there are two challenges that I've
faced being a woman in this field one is
I think that when a group of men get
together in general you see this in
small boys on up to you know
professional athletes but there's a you
know some competition comes out or even
some summer end Lee I mean friendly
aggression but as a woman that's a
little hard to deal with sometimes but
the strategy that I have found that
really helps me deal with it as to sort
of do my homework before meetings or
really do my research do some good
thinking on my own and then I'll come to
the meeting pretty confident and so if I
am met with any of that competition or
friendly aggression you know I'm
prepared and it doesn't it really
doesn't faze me so that's one thing that
can be a challenge another challenge I
think of being a woman in a
male-dominated field as I think men can
be extremely focused um even me slightly
obsessed with what they're doing which
gives them a great edge in in their
careers I'm not saying women can have
that too but I think women have also a
broader view and so maintaining a
work-life balance can be challenging in
this field so what and in my meticulous
way what I do is I kind of write down
each day what I do and roughly how much
time I've spent doing it and so I can be
confident that I've worked enough and
it's also really nice because then I can
look and see oh maybe I spent a little
too much time on that thing which didn't
give me good results and oh i didn't
spend i spent just a bit of time on that
i can flush out that a little bit more
so it helps me be more effective
essentially in my job so it helps me
maintain the work-life balance but as a
nice side effect it actually helps me
get a little bit higher view and
reflection on my work I think it's
pretty clear that technology is here to
stay and I think we're gonna buy new and
interesting ways to use technology and
if you're interested in technology you
should stay in the field if you're
interested in how technology is shaping
the future you should stay in the field
because it's evolving and it's changing
and you really can have impact and and
the way the ship sails researchers at
Microsoft Research come up with great
ideas for technologies and my team gets
to help them take those ideas and put
them in Microsoft products and we've
influenced a whole host of Microsoft
products ranging from being too office
to Windows to xbox I can point to many
different features that we have helped
researchers put into actual Microsoft
products probably would i look forward
to the most and my future at Microsoft
is just learning
the new technologies that come by
because that's that's essentially my
role just on the last project I got to
learn about cloud computing and
different web technologies and graphics
technologies and this was all just in 19
month project and who knows what the
next project will bring I don't know but
I i know i'll get to learn and and have
fun and work with great people